setting up your Google cloud platform
resources correctly can save you a lot
of trouble down the road let's look at
how to manage resources and the resource
hierarchy by adding new resources
managing permissions and creating labels
[Music]
when setting up your resource hierarchy
in the GCP console you'll need to be
assigned the right permissions such as
the organization administrator and
folder creator roles this will ensure
that you have the right permissions when
setting up the initial structure for
your organization but don't forget to go
back and review permissions after you're
set up to ensure only the right people
can update your resources the best place
to manage your resources is on the
resource management page which you can
find under IIM and admin this page shows
all the resources in an organization and
lets you manage them let's go through an
example of bringing on a new line of
business to an organization we'll start
by adding a folder directly under the
organization called Department why to do
this we can just click the create folder
button and type in department-wide a
folder can exist under the organization
or under another folder based on your
organization structure for example we
could create production and development
folders to help organize your projects
further for each department since
Department y is a new line of business
we'll create it at the organization
level just like folders when we create a
project we can choose a single parent
location such as our new folder now that
we have multiple lines of business our
shared infrastructure project should
probably have its own folder let's
create a new folder called shared
infrastructure after that we can move
the project under our new folder by
using the options menu
now our lines of business and our shared
infrastructure have their own
independent folders we can also manage
permissions on the right hand side for
the organization folders and projects
since we've just created a new folder
for our shared infrastructure team let's
make sure they have project creator
access to this new folder we can select
the folder and click add member let's
add the shared enfagrow and choose
project creator now members of the
shared enfagrow can create projects
under this folder but it looks like
everyone else in the organization can as
well that's because this permission is
being inherited from the organization we
can use the toggle to see which
permissions have been added directly or
inherited since permissions are
inherited folders are also a good way to
organize projects that have similar
permissions requirements google
recommends a least privileged approach
so you should only grant access to those
who absolutely need it let's go ahead
and remove the permission for everyone
in the org to create projects by
choosing the organization and removing
that permission other best practices
include using groups wherever possible
and to test permission changes before
making the actual change there's a link
below with more tips another way to
organize resources is by adding labels
which are key value pairs that you can
filter on for example it may make sense
to label projects with a component we'll
select Department X prod and apply a new
label called component and set it to
dashboard other common uses for labels
include distinguishing instances owned
by different call centers or teams as
we've shown the resource management page
is a great place to see what your
organization looks like and to manage
your resources check out the links below
for more information